all right best house gun I thought we'd
do another
omegle where I pretty much put Pitt pie
and the Chatham video and we'll see we
can find our so awesome talk to you
later
and it's me it's the fake pair the bad
girl done two weeks after you responded
on it that off that's awesome
this is actually PewDiePie ringer the
pewter path I don't
how's again bread nice meeting you
it's me how's the gun man
good guess what I I've been waiting I'm
sorry I've been waiting to tell you this
all right tell them I have a cat
I named it Stefano yeah can I meet him
yeah is he here yeah let me go get her
all right
safar ah okay I see him
Hey nice video bye
[Laughter]
what really no way I have been there for
like two hours
it's so funny to see you oh my god so
and I take a picture like everyone else
pinging you know what you know we do
this kiss video it's only you and me her
now
oh that's so awesome beauty it's awesome
to meet you
[Music]
how's the guy on Facebook just go to me
good to see you man oh thanks for coming
[Music]
[Applause]